dergin tokmak tänzer auf krücken
sein künstlername sticks angelehnt an
das englische wort für stöcke tanzen da
hat mir geholfen meinen geist und körper
zusammen zu verwenden
und da ich ja schon komplizierten körper
hatte war es schwierig nein zu wachsen
um das tanzen hat mir einfach sehr stark
geholfen
um das ganze zu verbinden also ich denke
mal ist es für mich das tanzen ist sowas
wie für viele menschen die der regierung
vielleicht ist der glaube an sich selbst
hat ihn stark gemacht
im alter von acht monaten erkrankte er
ging an kinderlähmung
während der ferien in der türkei der
heimat seiner eltern der vater ist
gastarbeiter in augsburg der deutschen
sprache kaum mächtig der gen wird
mehrere male operiert
doch die hoffnung einmal gehen zu können
zerbricht
trotz allem sei die eigentliche hürde
nicht seine behinderung gewesen
eine herausforderung war eigentlich
emigration hintergrund zu haben
als meine behinderung das war für mich
einfach normal als ich einfach okay ich
wusste ich habe eine behinderung mit der
kann ich das und das machen aber jetzt
irgendwie zu wissen bin ich jetzt hier
zu hause oder nicht das war irgendwie
das war nie sicher wirklich zu hause
fühlt sich top marques wenn er tanzt
seine leidenschaft erwachte mitte der
80er jahre als breakdance in augsburg
einzug in viele begannen die neuen
schritte zu bleiben
das schlüsselerlebnis war aber der
hollywood film breaking mit dem solo von
rodriguez es war der moment was mich
inspiriert hat was er kann keiner chip
auch und ich hab es dann auch geübt ich
habe diese szene mir bestimmt 1000 mal
angeguckt und versucht so paar tricks
was er gemacht hat
nach zu machen und ich hab es dann
später in meinem cousin gezeigt und der
man natürlich über übermäßig begeistert
und nahm ich vielleicht mit in diesem
jugendzentrum das war der erste moment
wo ich vor einem publikum getanzt hatte
der internationale durchbruch gelingt
2004 im cirque du soleil
doch die rolle des hinkenden engels
übersteigt seine körperlichen kräfte
nach zwei jahren täglicher
höchstleistung bricht tokmak auf der
bühne zusammen
ich war so motiviert einfach und ich
wollte immer meine nummer immer weiter
und weiter verbessern
bis der körper halt einfach mal
mitgemacht hat und von da es war falsch
los erst mal
aber ehrgeiz und wille siegen wieder
genesen tourt er noch einmal mit dem
cirque du soleil rund um den globus
insgesamt sechs jahre lang diese ganze
reiserei ich glaube dass das kommt noch
meine vorfahren bei ich habe diesen
diesen nomaden sind in mir und es fällt
mir ein bisschen schwer noch mal an
einem ort zu bleiben
vielleicht bin ich doch mobilitäts
professor geworden
seine eltern hätten sich für ihren sohn
eine laufbahn an der universität
gewünscht er hat seinen eigenen weg
gewählt
tokmak ist übrigens gelernter
technischer zeichner arbeitete einst im
büro im rollstuhl dann überwand er
hindernisse gab gas machte seinem traum
wahr
aus der top marques protest ich denke
mal wenn man limitiert ist auch das sind
das macht kreativ das ist
ich könnte mein leben vorstellen wo ich
perfekt auf die welt gekommen bin und
ich hab alles irgendwie ich habe für
nicht zu kämpfen also es ist irgendwie
auch eine auch ein geschenk das ich
bekommen habe
ich kann mir zwar heute erst nicht
laufen aber ich habe da ein bisschen
gelernt zu fliegen sticks in höhen von
aus eigener kraft